now huge advances in the treatment and
prevention of hiv
means people living with a virus in 2021
can
enjoy a long and healthy life but while
the science has moved on
perceptions haven't at least not as much
fewer than one
in five people know that someone living
with hiv who's on
effective treatment can't pass it on to
their partner well
the welsh rugby legend captain gareth
thomas
lords tackle hiv to quash the sigma
around the virus
once and for all here he is recording
the campaign podcast using them channels
is a great way
to be able to educate yourself which
will also give you then the power to be
able to educate other people
and treat people living with hiv the
same as you would treat anybody else
[Applause]
well gareth joins me now good to see you
this morning look first and foremost can
we just ask
i mean it's not long since you i think
it's not long since you came out never
mind then coming out with your diagnosis
how
how difficult has it been to actually
stand there and be a
be a you know a public figure standing
there saying i have hiv it must still be
quite difficult
um it's not i'll be honest it's not that
difficult for me because i have the
knowledge
i have the knowledge of what living with
hiv
means for me and how i can live a normal
happy life um what is important is that
i create
the environment that i have for
everybody else and by doing that we need
to give people
the correct information the correct
knowledge because even though through
the survey we've done with
vive healthcare and terence higgins
trust even though people feel like they
talk more
around the subject of hiv actually the
conversations they have in
don't have the correct narrative because
they don't have the correct facts
so it's really important that people
understand the facts and also that
people get tested because from the
you know some of the figures you've said
also another figure is that
um a lot of people feel like they don't
need to get tested
because they're not at risk so they feel
like they they're not a protected
characteristic so maybe they're not
from the lgbt community or black african
men and women and the reality is
is that living in in the uk at the
moment um
over half of the people living living in
the uk
with hiv are heterosexual and a third of
them
are women and half of them that third
are white so when we talk about
the um the understanding that we know
around hiv the reality is is that
there's so much more information that
needs to be put out there for
people to be able to have the the same
life that i have living with hiv
i mean it's remarkable that you know
these concepts are still about 40 years
you know that we've been dealing with
hiv
in the world and yet some of these are
pretty arcane attitudes still exist
yeah they're they they are archaic but
that's the reality of what we
we're having to deal with what we're
having to fight with you know just over
60 percent of people think that
somebody living with hiv can't have a
family um so it you know it is quite
horrific but then what that does for me
and everybody else to tackle hiv is
gives us purpose to continue
to deliver correct messages to create a
society to create an environment
where everybody not just people living
with hiv but everybody whether they're
living with or
affected by hiv can live
in a knowledgeable understandable
environment
um where people don't feel prejudiced
against don't feel discriminated
um against and that's why it's so
important
that organizations like vive healthcare
where over the last 40 years
you know they've created science and
medicine that have allowed
people living with hiv to live normal
happy healthy lives and i feel that we
also as much as we need to have the
information we need to celebrate that as
well
yeah absolutely i mean look what is more
important do you think i mean obviously
there is this key message that you know
if you're on the right medication you
get your viral load down to undetectable
then
you know you're simply not going to be
able to pass it on which is really
important but also
you know as you say that the people who
aren't coming forward for testing where
getting on the right medication is quite
literally going to be a lifesaver
who is the most important group to
tackle here
it's not a group to tackle i think it's
everybody's
responsibility to take a test whether
you feel you're in a
protected characteristic or not
everybody needs to have a test because
one of the highest rates of
transmissions are from people who don't
know
their status so knowing your state
that's invite is vitally important and
also
having the knowledge and information
that breaks down the fear
of people having the test and that's why
we've set up tackle hiv.org and not
tackle hiv because
that's a site and an organization and a
campaign that we've got together
to give people relevant information to
break down
the stigma to break down the
misunderstanding but also to break down
the fear